[Music]
welcome back to the break room everybody
we're thrilled to be here with you today
uh it's the daily nerdy news show that
keeps you up to date on what you need to
know okay and today what you need to
know we've got some Deadpool casting
news we've got some Penguin series
casting news it's still happening
besides James Gunn not name-dropping it
during his big announcement it's in the
Penguins yes we're excited for it uh and
is The Flash DC's no way home
how many Batmans how many Batmans
there's too many Batmans and how many
Batmans there's not enough Batman's uh
over there holding up all of the fingers
toys here koi's back today
I've just been here I told you I
threatened that I'd be in that corner to
yell about Flash yeah here we are
somebody opened up a recycling bin and
quite popped out uh and then
um the the the the the garbage bin
decoys recycling bin Brandon Barracks
over there the trash bags know what I'm
talking about hey here's a reminder if
you eat uh pizza and you have a pizza
box you can't recycle the pizza box if
it's got pizza juice all over too greasy
it's too greasy but you could you can
recycle a pizza box if there's no pizza
even if the Top's clean or pump the top
throw that in there but if there's Pizza
juice all over it also if if there is no
grease was it ever Pizza um
if you're doing some weird cauliflower
crust uh vegan stuff I mean it's fine
it's a good flatbread or whatever but
it's not pizza
um speaking of don't you lie to us oh no
that's it we lost speaking of not pizza
but still delicious
new rockstars is launching a new channel
this week everybody uh just a matter of
days the Deep dive is going live I think
we have a little Beautiful trailer
footage that we're just gonna play
welcome back to talk about it there Eric
Voss is the man to meet the legend uh is
branching out it's still under the new
Rockstar's umbrella uh but he's he's got
a separate Channel over there where he's
going to be doing kind of longer form
video essay kind of stuff investigations
he's calling some of them you know some
topics we cover here like one Division
and Loki but then other things
as much as we'd like he's got some hot
videos
uh some really great stuff and I think
he's gonna be doing a live breakdown on
Friday yes uh that you guys which we
watched a little play test of that and
it's really fun to see how his work his
mind works in real time also Eric is not
as somebody who's not been doing the
break room is a live stream virgin
and or not a virgin wait you know what
I'm saying he's he it's it's a newer
format to him so I encourage
to go watch that live stream to
overwhelm ing uh to you know over
stimulate Eric and and to show some
support for that new channel uh we're
really excited for it
um other things we're really excited for
a couple of us are wearing Brandon's got
your shirt the last time shirt uh
promote it uh there's a couple days left
I I don't I gotta be honest if you're
seeing Ant-Man opening weekend and you
order that shirt right now I don't know
that it would get to you by opening
weekend but maybe maybe you're not
seeing it till the second week yeah you
could order that and it'll be there in
time then I'm I'm wearing our last of us
shirt there's still four episodes of
that show left that's right so hey by
episode six or so you could be watching
it while rocking that show will be
living in your head rent free all year
long great finale shirt great second
viewing shirt yes yes all of those in
more available over at nerdriot.shop uh
We've also got these goofy meme
thumbnails these are very serious okay
that's fair my mini mugs meme mugs meme
mugs hey what was he cooking what was he
uh let's get into the headlines
everybody what you came here for
uh some some Marvel news to kick things
off Anthony Mackey says that Captain
America New World Order will start
filming next month March 2023. that's
good to hear he also talked about the
difference between him and Chris Evans
Captain America mainly that team Wilson
doesn't have a super serum that is
correct uh to quote Mackie his
superpower is his Humanity I like that I
don't think that goes well against the
bullet I'll tell you what I'll tell you
what I take that super soldier serum so
wait since his superpower is is Humanity
could you say that he is superhuman ah
Amity I feel like it's like the Batman
Superman thing right that that brain is
the thing that makes him so super and
therefore that equivalent in the world
of Avengers I'm excited to see some
Ultra Humanity from this man yeah there
was also a good quote from Anthony
Mackey saying he was going to give uh
Harrison Ford a full breakdown of the
MCU it's just send them our way stand
there we are ready yeah
information today that Harrison Ford
will be playing the president of the
United States in New World Order that's
confirmation I thought I saw that
headline today I think that was kind of
late breaking
um there's a president during secret
Invasion uh there's gonna be a president
there they you can see it is uh Dermot
moroney I believe yeah yeah uh uh
Jessica's breakdown of what kind of
forever talked about there's like a new
scroll where they say the presidency we
haven't had a president's name in the
MCU since Alice right it's all joining
Iron Man 3. but it's kind of just been
up in the air like who was president
when the snap happened like what's going
on uh so they're gonna get back into the
the higher hierarchy of power in the
United States of America the MCU I think
that makes sense for the government
stuff that's about to come with
Thunderbolts you need that
infrastructure and you don't want to do
it suddenly if it's like oh now we've
got a government like I think it's smart
to lay those seeds the president is a
scroll and then Ross has to take over
the human that comes in after the
cleanup New World Order if you're
talking about World Order world leaders
makes a lot of sense right like that
that would if a bunch of them were just
revealed to be Scrolls and you have to
suddenly have a new power structure if
Russ if Harrison Ford has Thunderbolt
rock is the president he better get on
Air Force One at one point and tell
someone to get off at this point get off
point I want to kick someone off a
helicary yeah
so Anthony Mackey uh I think currently
shooting or maybe it's just wrapped the
uh Twisted Metal series I think that's
what he's been working on for a while
we're excited for that as well if that
exists I think that's supposed to come
out this year I believe maybe yeah such
a good game give us some Twisted Metal
news Sony
um Deadpool 3 has a villain
uh the deadline announced that Emma
Corin uh most notable for their
performance uh as a younger Princess
Diana not the most recent older uh about
to be killed in a car wreck Princess
Diana what spoiler spoiler yeah if you
watch the crown I Believe season four
Olivia Coleman was still the queen at
the time this is when Charles first met
Diana and she was very sheepish
uh that was Emma Corin yes a younger
Diana yeah that's kind of their main
role and supposedly the news is they've
not only been cast in the movie but
they're playing a villain right I saw a
lot of speculation of danger who is a uh
physical representation a manifestation
of the AI from the X-Men's Danger Room
come to Forum I believe created by John
Sweden during his ass
which is great that wrote a guy but
great run yeah
best written Cyclops you'll ever read my
guy and it's only like 12 issues to like
the commitment's small like it keeps
going but if you want to just read an
arc you could just read those 12 and
never ever read an X-Men I saw the rumor
of danger popular and then they
immediately shot it down there are other
scoopers being like no way no way no way
but I don't know danger would be cool
well it would allow for the Multiverse
with them traveling through things
because you could have an AI element you
could have like danger room as like a
bait and switch you could also allow for
certain X-Men to Cameo and they have to
be like haha that was actually just a
danger room and they've never really
they haven't really done them
three when it was just a sentinel moment
yeah they had a danger room like but
also we never really in first class
right or did we see it for like a second
In First Class I don't remember I don't
remember it in first class but it's been
a while so I've been dying immediately
oh you know the guy that can't be killed
that made a lot of sense
um but I think that danger would work
I like that I like and feels like a
raising of the stakes when it comes to
Villages
John Ham so close we're so close
but but we're we're very excited for
Deadpool that's a next year joint that's
a 2024 release uh so it's great to hear
the you know the casting hopefully
they're not too far off from shooting on
that um and then another casting news
again the cast of The Penguin series
that'll be coming out on HBO Max
following Colin Farrell's awesome
portrayal from the Batman uh they've
announced four different actors uh a few
of these people I'm gonna butcher their
last names let's do it uh could I have
done research before we started rolling
to find phonetic pronunciations you yes
absolutely I did not have time to do
that and apologies to folks that are
personal relatives of these actors uh
renzi Feliz I believe I got that right
uh from Marvel's runaways and in Kanto
uh Michael Kelly who is kind of the
fixer character from House of Cards
those Seasons a guy has has worked a ton
it was a fun tough guy actor uh okay
this is a tough Lane sure
okay uh actress from the expanse right
uh she's got a great voice great love we
love her voice and then Deidre O'Connell
who just won a Tony last year do you
know what role she won okay
I don't know if those are dramatic you
know what what they want a Tony for
calling please yeah call in uh we are
live uh throw that in the chat
um Lindsay Feliz is really excited
because he he's so good in runaways and
he was young then I haven't seen him in
Kanto I wouldn't have physically seen
him but I it'd be cool to see him come
back he was really like a force in that
show and and we don't know any of the
roles these folks are playing uh you
know maybe some underworld figures maybe
other gothamites cops who knows
um but we're so excited for that show we
haven't we haven't heard a lot it's kind
of shifted in concept over time there
was originally going to be two shows and
then there was gonna be a gcpd showing
an asylum Arkham show and then it seems
like just the penguin show kept going
but it also seemed like so I've been
watching a lot of the Colin Farrell
Oscar stuff because that man
so he's been saying that basically the
idea is it takes place like five days
after Gotham Falls and the power still
moisture on the ground yes
and then um
I think it leads up to like right before
the second Batman movie and it's
basically that power shift and I think
some of the things he discussed was he
was kind of a part of pitching it like
on the on the set he was saying like I
love this suit I want to play this more
and they can do time jumping because you
can make the Prosthetics older and
younger so I think it's going to be life
here going through different times you
could see him as a kid coming up in the
kind of mob or whatever yeah and like
all the possibilities for all the
henchmen level villains that might not
have enough going to have a full movie
out of them you could have like a
villain of the week but with villains
would be interesting yeah and this
allows for certain characters that we
like maybe don't get the chance to have
fleshed out when they're in the Batman 2
you get to have them like oh we know
this guy now I'm very excited for them
again yeah the Reeves uh output thus far
has been great we're excited for more so
I love that idea of like using a kind of
a full prosthetic thing to age I mean d
aging technology is hot right now right
uh dial a destiny prominently features
uh some younger Harrison Ford stuff and
and you know I think think results May
Vary there for different viewers
sometimes that stuff is great and
sometimes it just doesn't click for you
so I love a practical approach to doing
it I love that that was part of the
pitch because that makes it like if you
know that's what you want you can write
a story around the benefit of practical
effects a lot of times like I think Stan
Winston what he did with Jurassic Park
the strength of those first movies was
when they went into it they shaped
action sequences around the fact they
knew it was going to be practical
augmented with that kind of CGI if
you're writing a script and you know
you're going to be able to manipulate
time and special effects and you've got
an actor like Colin Farrell you can make
this incredible crime Lord Saga and it's
not a surprise the way you narratively
struggle that and then when you get to
the Batman they could have the court of
owls because they've established it in
the show they could have certain like
gothamites be already invested that
could lead to hush you can have a lot
more of the corruption and Gotham in a
way we've never seen before just by
having the show bridge the gap yeah Eric
was high on Corner valves for the Batman
because it did seem like a lot of
teasing trailers and hush but I love the
idea that it's it is there they're just
like setting this groundwork like Reeves
is like let me put a lot of stuff in
here that can show up later which I
really like there's also uh Mr Freeze
has been the rumor for a long time he
was pretty public about that and one of
the things that the court of owls is one
of their only weaknesses is cold so I
think it'd be really interesting if you
have the court of owls I know it's like
by the way but like it'd be really
interesting
it's chilly it's chilly for these owls
someone checked the HVAC it's freezing
but if you've got that Arnold moment
where he has to help he sees through his
cold hearts and he helps Batman with the
owls because he realizes Nora didn't
love him as much as he loved her all
right we do have an update Deidre
O'Connell won a Tony Award for best
actress in a play for the play Dana h
not familiar with that work uh but
looking forward to her uh character in
The Penguin series
um Eric Kripke who's the sheer Runner of
the boys and is a lot of fun on Twitter
um has said that there will be more boys
right they're currently shooting season
four
um he he mentioned that he's kind of
currently prepping to direct the finale
of season four uh and he made a point of
saying it's not the series finale yes so
there will be a season five I think
Amazon would be happy to have there be
as many seasons of the boys as Eric
Kripke is down to make and the cast uh
so that's great we're I think we're we
think we're getting season four later
this year they're shooting it right
they're almost done shooting it takes a
while for post-production everything on
that side well they started shooting
like right after they went right into it
yeah season three was yeah like last
fall kind of uh tweet I think Carl Urban
tweeted about like we're on set like
we're filming because they got delayed
because of covid because they were
trying to do every year every summer I
believe they were in the summer kind of
cadence and then yeah they got kind of
they were on that weird coveted cycle
where they were just about to get going
and it also done so it really put them
behind uh but yeah they're trying to
catch up again and plus we get uh gen V
this year yes
I think that might be a spring release
and Ted lasso was cheeky because they
announced a while ago it was winner but
boy oh boy is it this winter March 15th
beware the gods of March 10 last of
season three that trailer just dropped
today that's a little a field of a new
rockstars otherwise that would have made
it into the headlines but I brought it
in but no but let us know let us know in
the chat if we should start covering Ted
lasso more uh all shaved adjust the
mustache we do Ted lasso every week
um and lastly and now this is teasing
what we're our main topic uh for today
uh we might have gotten a first look at
Michael Keaton as Bruce Wayne in The
Flash movie Sans Cowell uh this photo
was circulating online look at that you
want to get nuts let's get nuts
the wig work uh there is par Excellence
uh again we you know there's that great
shot in The Flash trailer of somebody
with long white hair from the back
version I mistakenly on our post Super
Bowl episode I'm mistakenly said it was
somebody's shirtless because it is an
alabaster sweater I think they're
wearing until Eric Boss did the
breakdown and kind of zoomed in enhanced
I was pretty sure that was just a a
fleshy white uh body but it is somebody
wearing a sweater long white hair
now he doesn't have long light here in
that image it's also this is supposedly
from like the trailer we'll see in the
movies like ahead of probably like
Ant-Man and wasp this weekend uh but it
is it is interesting he's like looking
directly at the camera it doesn't seem
like a thing you'd see in a movie I
don't know that's why I didn't believe
like when this image started going
around I was like I don't think this is
like an official skill in the way that
it's like we're gonna go to all the
multiverses including yours
whoa 3D movies
um what if Michael Keaton as Bruce Wayne
introduces the movie in a framing device
like Rocky Horror Picture Show or
Princess Bride or something Never Ending
Story would you like to hear a story
about a flash or whatever
um yeah that feels a little you're
probably wondering how I got here
record scratch
um anyways we're excited give us all the
Keaton we will no matter how many images
they release of him we will play them
all uh we're so excited for that and
we're going to come back uh to that
character in that film in a moment first
you want to shout out the folks helping
us bring the show to you this week
nordvpn who uh we're very excited to be
sponsoring us and as part of that uh
Thursday we're doing our nordvpn Nord
Movie Club that's right uh again one of
the great benefits of using a VPN if
you're not already in addition to kind
of protecting your privacy and and uh
not letting your ISP know everywhere you
go on the internet uh they let you
change your geolocation uh which is
super helpful when it comes to streaming
services so let's say you just subscribe
to One streaming service the old Netflix
for instance uh and you're like oh a
movie I want to see is not on us Netflix
well using a VPN you can change what
country you're in and you can access UK
Netflix Japan Netflix whatever Netflix
tap into all of their libraries which
are still in English
um and get to watch those without
needing to subscribe to a second server
this this week we're going to do
Zombieland
this is inspired by the ongoing success
we're like oh what could be a fun one to
revisit Zombieland not on Netflix in the
US it's on the Netflix in Japan the
Netflix is my grandfather would sing
it's on the Netflix uh it's it's there
yeah it's streaming there you can watch
that and I think it'll be really fun I
haven't seen that movie probably since
it came out wow yeah full disclosure
I've never seen it oh no I have seen
Zombieland double double tap a hundred
times
the origins of double you're probably
the same gifts
I know some of the some of the reveals
and stuff like that but I'm very excited
to watch it so we got Deadpool oh that's
a good point same director right yeah
right the road to Deadpool yes
um so join us if you don't already
subscribe to nordva VPN do that uh you
know again you can tap into servers in
60 different countries it's super fast
it doesn't slow anything down there's no
lag time it's the fastest VPN out there
technically uh it's great on you know
you can use it one subscription on up to
six devices and it works on all the
different uh operating systems uh you
can join us for our Nord movie club
without needing to rent Zombieland or
download it or anything like that grab
your exclusive nordvpn deal by going to
nordvpn.com break room the name of our
show to get a huge discount off your
nordvpn plan plus a bonus gift it's
completely risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee and join us on
Thursday of this week we'll talk about
Zombieland brought to you by nordvpn
okay we want to come back obviously
we're abuzz about that Flash trailer we
got Sunday night
um there's so much it's a hell of a it's
a three minute long it's a long trailer
so there's a lot in it and you know one
of the big reveals there that was the
first time we had gotten hints obviously
of Keaton being in it
um should we cover tips real quick
should we cover 10 lasso I will say only
62 percent actually 62 saying no uh I
guess ouch Savvy because it would be
crowding out other content maybe they
just want they're like stick to the
stuff it might be the best show on TV
and I love last of us but Ted lasso is
how my heart has people aren't ready to
face hey can we run run that same Poll
for succession because
today's the poll day about next season
okay uh we gotta keep Evan and dashler
back there working our asses off just to
keep up with our poll demands
um but right we knew Michael Keaton was
going to be in this movie and I there
were rumors but we had yet to see any
images of Ben Affleck yeah until this
trailer that's a surprise I think and
not only but I have like multiple
costume Ben Affleck yeah that's great
man
um yeah and so you know
um
the kind of leads one to believe is this
movie kind of doubling as a no-way home
for the dceu right we already know
there's kind of Multiverse variant
zod's back
surprise right Michael Shannon yes
seeing that again especially as like a
character who we saw you know die yeah
well a long time reborn as doomsday yes
his head right on a monster's body or
something like that uh but it is very
reminiscent of no way home like can you
I don't think they're gonna try and
redeem Zod uh but is it are we gonna see
other villains from the past kind of get
brought in here well let's let's come
back to the villains okay uh we have to
assume though they gave us a lot right
we got super girl we saw two Batmans
multiple flashes a Hint it may be a
villain there and a couple shots near
the end but we have to assume there was
stuff they didn't show us right
including probably some pretty key plot
elements
um so who do we think also we know
there's some stuff that didn't tell us
because it's since been cut out of the
movie we know Henry Cavill shot a cameo
for this movie at one point that has
since been excised because that was in
some of the back and forth or has it or
has it that's true yeah the right thing
to drop the week of and be like come see
the movie just kidding it works for
Black Adam uh and we know there have
been cameos from Jason Momoa that have
been rumored uh some other rumors but
let's let's begin with before we get to
like what other Batmans could be in this
movie do we expect any other
Snyder vs era characters that we have
yet to see beyond Ben Affleck appear in
this movie well there was that you know
there was a Japanese trailer commercial
for Shazam that seemed to show Wonder
Woman oh yeah right the you see it from
above you see the gauntlets uh it
doesn't look like his his sister uh it
looks like Wonder Woman there's the
gauntlets there's a little armband uh
the character was like holding the staff
McGuffin from that movie right lightning
was coming down it looks like Wonder
Woman right I wouldn't be surprised to
see Wonder Woman in this I I know
they're kind of they are trying to kind
of do away with the Snyder verse
characters but given that we're still
gonna get Aquaman at the end of some
point in this decade
and I I wouldn't I would be I would be
surprised if there wasn't like some
other characters that show up well even
the dialogue just to kind of put a
little bow on it that's what I think
it's going to be because the dialogue is
very clearly allowing for this to come
back there's a line in this that says
like we have to save this universe
because it's what my mom's in and it's
clear that that's not his Universe yeah
they could literally leave Ezra in that
universe and then tag back in later and
have it be an elsewhere that percolates
over here and that could be how Aquaman
like comes out later is that could be
that little side universe so I think if
they're gonna have that be like let's
see how it does and check back in the
best thing to do would be to have us
remember how much we love these
characters like have a lot of cameos be
like oh we want them back and have them
over here so I could see gal I could see
lots of folk from the the Justice League
I get to see Martian Manhunter like they
could really expand to have like a
Justice League moment yeah it would be
interesting uh especially because we
know uh that
um uh yeah this is kind of like their
Multiverse open door policy of like
everyone can live somewhere it'll be
fine you guys can come come take refuge
over here we're all assuming too that
they're kind of following the comic
storyline of this place that he goes to
is a place without metahumans except for
we had a long discussion about this is
Superman a meta human he's not an alien
but right he's still classified as a
meta-human it's very strange so they
have like super girl hair but presumably
no other meta-humans they don't exist if
they're following that storyline but it
might just be a situation with no
they're there because no one has stepped
forward yet everyone's kind of unwilling
to do it and the only one that has
stepped for it is Batman who's not a
metahuman though the wiki sometimes
listen at a human because he's Peak
human I guess you would say uh if he was
the only one right and he cleaned up
Gotham City and retired and they were
all like we shouldn't come forward or
maybe they'll reveal there was some sort
of uh you know sokovia Accord s
legislation that was like forced Batman
to retire and everyone else was like I'm
not going to get into it it's too much
uh so yeah maybe the conclusion of this
movie is like no I'm here we got this
big Gathering moment I'm here too or
when he goes back to his Universe if he
does or if they have another folded in
Universe like there's a lot of options
with this and especially because it
seems like it travels more than just the
one like I feel like we're gonna have
moments where he's looking and he's like
going through stuff so they're gonna be
like 30 second cameos they could have
shot in one blue screen room and it also
looks like to me that we're getting
something that I don't think anything
has done in this way in that it looks
like kind of a uh no way home was an
annual an event movie a comic book that
you'd pick up by itself and you could
experience but it's better if you've
read the other ones right this to me
feels like almost like a a double page
spread Jam piece from multiple artists
that are like Jim Lee's drawing Batman
and Casada is drawing like Superman
because it looks like he's modeling his
directing style after each of the
directors we talked about it yesterday
yeah the Snyder shots look like it's
muschetti doing Snyder the Burton shots
have a burton angle to them so it'd be
really interesting to see all of these
villains directed in that way and then
what that would look like at the end of
the film as much Yeti firms up his style
is it gonna feel like a different
Justice League because of muschetti's
flavor so I'm really excited to see like
a new take on any of these folk as we go
forward this year to the new Jeep yeah
and and as you know obviously Zod is a
standard first era villain uh you kind
of mentioned him turning into Doomsday
well somebody who was partially
Lex Luthor do we see him in this movie
no no okay fair I don't think you're
moving on
um now there uh let's pivot here to the
mangiliano's finally Deathstroke oh yeah
yeah
as was foretold in the uh the sacred
texts they just get off that yacht after
all these years they finally pay off
that yeah still floating
um so right we we know we're getting two
Batmans uh Batman yeah
um do we get a third Batman in this
movie now the potentials here right
let's just a quick review of other
live-action Batman uh right we could see
George Clooney I think uh that rumor has
been kind of aggressively shot down Val
Kilmer as we saw in Top Gun Maverick uh
he's out there you know he's a little
physically limited but willing to show
up for kind of a legacy property that
he's a big part of and then obviously
the more recent Batman we've got Robert
Pattinson in the sales world and
Christian Bale from the the Nolan a lot
of people after the trailer dropped
right we're like oh that's Nolan's
that's the Nolan bike right the
motorcycle we see two wheels
bike with him with with that character
uh bad Fleck got the idea because he met
like the other Batman he's like oh nice
that's a good idea okay I can actually
make it a little better a little bit
more stable by having two wheels yeah uh
I like that idea
um I you know we'd all love to see like
Nolan's Batman show up I mean that that
trilogy has a nice bow on the end sure
nice doing a lot of heavy lifting there
some people don't agree with how it
ended but that was like a Batman who was
like I had a I had a good run 10 rough
years in Gotham and I cleaned it also
that was like the most self-contained
Trilogy there's no mention of any other
superheroes or super there's no super
powers at all in that trilogy right
right but yeah well has the power of
living forever I don't know I mean the
Lazarus Pit was like implied but not as
much shown yeah but but hey again like
you said if you're kind of doing these
alternate timelines you can kind of bend
a lot more interesting would be not you
know uh Christian Bale is Batman but
seeing Nightwing just for yeah like
Nightwing comeback Joseph either as
Robin or Wing like just that blue chest
man that'd be so cool to see that bird
that'd be incredible
um now press
rest in peace uh trash bag uh who's got
the best name uh pointed out with a
super chat thank you since we are
bringing back Tim Burton Batman is it
possible we will see any of the villains
now Jack Nicholson
uh alive and well not making a lot of
films these days uh made I think I
reported almost 100 million dollars or
something insane first wasn't he yeah
and he got a back-end deal on that first
Batman so he made way more money than
anybody involved in Batman probably more
money than anybody has ever made from a
superhero movie
um would he come back would we want to
see uh that joker or any of the
burton-era villains well we were talking
about this too a little bit in the
office right like a lot of those
villains die they're usually killed in
the movies uh and it's like a big plot
point of the Zod died as well right
right well his head lived uh here he is
doing great uh a big plot point of the
Burton movies is that Batman gets to
kill the person who killed his parents
it's like and Val Kilmer is actually
playing like the same Batman yeah as the
Michael Keaton Batman he's continuing
the story because when he meets Robin
there's a big really smart platform like
Robert wants to kill the people who
killed his parents right and Bruce Wayne
is able to say like look kid I did it
and doesn't fix anything it just makes
you more angry and more dark without Val
Kilmer Batman in his feelings in a great
way yeah
uh it's not bad uh so yeah it's either
gonna bring back to me villain long
story short the penguin I want to see it
speaking of speaking of Prosthetics
being able to age down there it is I say
karma karmically there's one that
mirrors Andrew Garfield though if
there's one character that should come
back they're now in the Limelight
they're doing well in their career they
were supposed to get a spin-off and then
didn't because a certain movie where
that character played basketball took
over that script and sullied that
character's name I think Michelle
Pfeiffer might be the back of that head
we see what if that's her gray hair
okay I want I want Michelle if I need to
do some analysis on the breadth of
shoulders
and we know she is definitely not
against uh superhero film appearances uh
shout out quantumania coming out this
week yeah I mean and hey I mean iconic
Mr Freeze performance from Arnold out
there
Jim coming in on my tires again
yeah a lot of these uh a lot of these
actors are not working as often anymore
but God it would be great I mean again
as great as it is to see Molina and
Defoe and all these people kind of
Michael Keaton Batman dies and we get
like uh you know Tears in Heaven moment
where like he's walking up the stairs to
heaven and all of his villains are up
there like come back baby we missed you
there's only one live-action theatrical
Robin and we haven't seen him in a long
time Chris O'Donnell you come off that
TV and you get back in that nipple suit
you could create that had a Super Chat
suggesting the hand that we see instead
of being uh Burton Batman it's actually
Thomas Wayne so in the in the TV thing
when we saw the back of the head we see
like a finger touching the picture of uh
Thomas and Martha and little Brucie uh
if that's like uh a Tom they said Thomas
Keaton kind of confided but if that's
like a Thomas Wayne from a different
dimension that comes in and is able to
uh interact or something weird like that
because in Flash in the flashpoint yeah
Thomas plane's a big factor yeah it's
not Bruce Wayne it's Thomas weight his
son died instead of London yeah that
would be an interesting crossover if
they get someone to play Thomas Wayne
who comes into a universe where his son
is still alive and you know they're able
to interact
yeah the Ben Affleck suit being
different would be an interesting thing
if that's Thomas Wayne in the blue and
gray like what if what if Ben Affleck's
playing Thomas Wayne and as a mislead or
the thing I'd love to see is the Snyder
never got to lean into the Thomas Wayne
Jeffrey D Morgan and Jeffrey D Morgan
said over and over again he'd love to
play Thomas Wayne as this else world so
that's probably my MVP of the Snyder
verse coming back Hey Thomas Wayne
murderous Jeffrey Dean Morgan for even
like a 10-minute sequence yeah that
would be I love that uh real quick a
couple other uh well-rounded mom uh as
always uh love to hear from you I want
to see Val Kilmer Batman yes as well as
Edward nigma yeah love both of those
um my succession poll uh doing about the
same man
I think people like these series that
we're referencing they just don't want
to necessarily see new rock stars talk
about them and that's fair uh we'll
watch those in our downtime
um jealous x891 saying I want a Batman
to become red death in The Flash
do you know are you familiar with red
death uh ish but I I don't know if that
would work for the story because that
almost need to be its own story it's
it's almost as deep as the Thomas Wayne
else world so it'd be hard to tell that
many Batman but that would be a way to
have another Batman well like red death
I don't remember angry or Batman than
the murderer but it'd be interesting to
see to see like the The Duality of the
angry Batman with whoever they
introduced yeah so it goes so far into
your anger yeah or what that leads to
I'm also wondering if we end the movie
with basically our new Batman like are
they gonna oh the hot new dude yes
because based on The Bold and The Brave
Batman yeah do we end this film because
we know they're doing reshoots like as
recently as like or weeks ago they were
still shooting stuff so what if they end
the film with the universe is imploding
and we get to meet them that way because
even like a Comic-Con announcement is
huge but a surprise casting announcement
in a movie that's yeah that's the first
we hear of it right by seeing this oh
they keep it secret they film it on the
green like in-house and then love it big
big Rags asking uh you know the chances
we'll see like either a CW flash or uh
for you old heads out there in the 90s
they had like a Flash TV show uh seeing
like that because there are I mean the
comics obviously Barry Allen is not the
only flashlight multiple flashes and you
know them teasing the Batmans in this
but yeah why not have more flashes
especially because this is a Flash movie
not a Batman movie right thank you I'm
glad someone said um so they don't want
as much as like yeah I don't think that
would hold them back from having a lot
of quick cameos yeah they don't want to
build major plot arcs around characters
that are not a flash Eric and his
breakdown pointed out like there's a
character you see we kind of barely see
that it looks like one of the flashes is
fighting uh that could be there was like
this toy leak of like a Kryptonian flash
or something like that like there's
probably another McGuffin here
that's not like the big bad yeah no
movie no I think it's bad at this movie
but there's probably another bigger
batter also the in the flash I would
hope in The Flash movie we give him his
flashiness but like there's a shot where
the two flashes are with Supergirl that
was released two years ago now and the
suit is the Batman suit right right with
like the flash over it so I wonder if
we're gonna meet a flash that's like the
mirror to that and that's a reverse
faster that's our yellow flash because
even like that guy could turn out to be
a bad guy that's in that shot of it so
many flags um uh we ran a poll should we
do more polls 86 coming in yay now I
will say yeah also also people that
answer polls are always going to be Pro
polls
um yeah on the uh paint dementia saying
on the topic of flash do we think we'll
see a reverse flash at all you're kind
of I really think we need to because I I
think the conversation about what power
I think the mirror of Thomas Wayne and
Batman is using power incorrectly but I
think the Flash Movie should have a
flash using power incorrectly otherwise
it's kind of missing that that core but
it is also a story that's trying to be
telling an origin and a flash point and
starting and ending a universe so I
don't know what they're going to get to
yeah uh also shout out Fray girl
birthday tomorrow Happy Birthday
a very silly Valentine's Day segment
coming up saying it's sexy okay silly
sexy it's celexi
um Christopher Baker any chances we'll
ever cover Star Trek you know what we
are fans of the Star Trek franchises
it's a little bit there's so much Star
Trek and it's kind of a um bifurcated
fan base or whatever that it's tough for
us to get a big enough audience to
justify the content that's the honest
answer there whereas like Marvel
releases are kind of uh monoculture so
to speak or big DC releases Star Trek
there's there's so much and they're kind
of more Niche uh but hey we're still
open to it yeah foreign
wrap up this uh topic right we know that
there are at least two uh James Gunn
projects that he has hinted at but not
like titled or officially announced
right and his quotes around these were
on the first one he said uh and and
these might not necessarily be direct
James gun projects just DC projects
whatever something so totally unique
that the idea itself is giving away too
much when it may not come out for two or
three years uh an idea so unique it's
just naming it will be like a spoiler
good so now we were kind of speculating
uh maybe is that also because like he's
going to do a post-credit reveal he's
got to get through he wants to wait for
like show it on screen and that's the
big reveal of it in some way right I
think I know what it is I got I got high
hopes so in the way that Sony has done
something really interesting with all
their Spider-Man villains that don't
work they kind of fold them in the next
like we were supposed to have a craven
and now we're getting a craving movie
We're supposed to have culture and then
Spider-Man used vulture like they tend
to go like that's a good idea what if
after all of the attempts that Guillermo
del Toro made to make justice league
dark we already have Constantine
potentially coming back okay Swamp Thing
has been announced who better to make
detective chimp work than James Gunn if
we get justice league dark and if you
announce that that follows that quote
perfectly if you know exactly what that
is once you announce it and it shows the
direction of those characters by the end
I think it's justice league dark I love
like that's the announcement that's like
too big so it's too big so it's genre
redefining I would love him to do
justice league dark before he does a
Justice
little palette cleanse uh and then the
other project he has mentioned offhand
is uh a director working on a really
fantastic other project that may take
him a little more time than some other
people and this is what we've speculated
on the breaker before about like what
directors take a while between projects
or whatever and and who knows this could
be because this director is really busy
Z with a lot of other stuff right now a
baby that has to grow up still he's been
to the future he knows this baby's going
to be a big director John Connor
just give it time
um so that's interesting and that's like
you know we know Jim's man gold is
probably working on a Swamp Thing
projects this is maybe similar it could
be even an else worlds project who knows
but
um could either of these maybe tie into
another Batman I mean here's the thing
for DC
Batman movies make a lot of money right
yeah everybody loves Batman uh there's
yet to be a Batman movie that wasn't
financially successful so like it
behooves them I mean we already know
we're getting one kind of in the gun
verse while the Matt Reeves Universe
continues would they ever roll out a
third that concurrent Batman scene I
think you can do Batman Beyond and go to
the Future go away to the phone oh I
would do that
especially if you if you set up if you
set up either Michael Keaton or Fred
there Ben Affleck to be old Batman's old
Bruce Wayne yeah let's go to the Future
Baby if bat if Ben Affleck ends uh The
Flash movie not in his Universe anymore
he's like well I'm too old to fight here
but uh I'll find some kid and and help
him out and then to make it meta he
directs it because it's him directing
another Batman from behind directing
himself as a Batman he's the guy in the
chair he's the guy in the chair looking
right into camera
uh well uh we're gonna transition here
now Tommy's not here to to roll the
graphic but we got a fun little
mandatory fun though that's right that's
right uh a special Valentine's go ahead
run that graphic
there it is it doesn't count it doesn't
count unless we run the graphic
um so in honor of being Valentine's Day
uh it's also Wick week as we all know
we've marked it we've marked our
calendars
um the announcement was it was the Grand
Canyon what's the poster today it was it
some might argue it wasn't the best Wick
day Tuesday of week week is never the
best day I mean everybody knows yeah I
mean you can't hit a home run every day
right so today in honor of it being
Valentine's Day they released like a
series of Valentine's Day cards uh there
there's some of them that like you could
download and send to your significant
other who's never seen a wick movie and
it's like what does this mean where am I
why is Keanu Reeves so upset why why is
he upset because his dog oh I love you
too yeah uh that said I've killed his
wife and then uh some angry Mobsters
killed um
inspired by uh you know one of our
favorite action franchises showing some
love we want to show some love for our
favorite franchise yeah so each of us
has crafted a Little Valentine to one of
our favorite franchises IP fandoms what
have you
uh Brandon do you want to check this out
I'll go first okay hit my music hit my
music
this Valentine's Day I wanted to send a
special message to the fandom closest to
my heart on this very special time of
year you've been there for me over the
years consistently getting better and
always subverting my expectations sure
there may be some out there who
criticize you for the way you look
they may say you're just a pale
imitation of someone more popular more
beloved that your edginess is just a
cheap device to get people to pay
attention but I say name
you're more than that baby you're my
rock you are my Foundation you are my
tiny little man that crawls up a urethra
only to expand rapidly exploding the
body that you read through is attached
to that's right this Valentine's Day I
want to thank the boys for always being
the brightest spot in my long year thank
you for being you [__] soups wow
[Applause]
I like you did that great Valentine's
Day card technique where you list yeah
all the bad things people say oh yeah
yeah that's the thing my wife loves the
most on Valentine's Day other people say
you're not that great but I mean that's
lovely I disagree with everyone else uh
quit do you have a little oh I do yeah
this is I'm more of a an off the Dome uh
presenter of a valentine it's like Heath
Ledger in A Knight's Tale I need a team
but then I take it on my own uh
the thing I love
about this entire Community is it's not
just a community it's not just a fandom
it's not just a group of people sharing
in agnostic church it's a family
and this family lives a quarter mileage
this family knows that you can have any
beer you want as long as it's a Corona
this family knows that the best way to
find out whether it's going to be tuners
or American muscle is to line up cars
have a lot of people dance and then kind
of show the end of the race through
cutaways this family knows that Civics
with spoon engines are the only way to
steal DVD VCR combos this is the most
loving family in the world that accepts
that even death isn't permanent in this
world this family knows that you can
have Easter eggs and loving references
and all of these things that evolve like
a tolkiness mythology through time and
that's something that starts like a
beautiful first date love at first sight
when you're doing something as simple as
just small robbery can evolve into the
biggest love affair of all time that
literally sends Your Love To The Moon in
a Fiero this is what love can be when
you are welcome at the barbecue when you
come back and you know the value of tuna
no crust family is all that love is and
the fast family is all that love is
wow okay well you know beautiful stuff
I'm a man of not that many words okay
and I'm also an elder Millennial so I
wrote this down okay but don't don't let
that
uh take anything away from the sincerity
of my message okay
because you know how much I love the
Dune franchise
let me count the weights okay okay I
love you like sand worms love the sound
of feet on a racket soil baby okay
that's how much I love it I love you
like a hearkenin loves black latex
that's how much I love doing it okay I
love you
like the Freeman people love Recycling
and consuming their own body flu you
gotta do it there's that much water
that's right it's a harsh environment
okay and I love you way more than Paula
tradies love seeing visions of himself
becoming a crazy christ-like savior to
Millions because he actually doesn't
love that at all it's a core Conflict at
the heart of his character that's how
much I love you dude okay Happy
Valentine's Day the spice must flow
um that's beautiful thank you a couple
handful of chat people in the chat
saying they loved eternals my people I
don't know oh yeah okay yeah they're
doing this for uh yeah absolutely and
this is a day about love so why not
celebrate the things we love rather than
worrying about the things that we didn't
love right
um Ilia Milano more anime coverage
there's actually there's a little pink
there's a peek behind the curtain
um because of Japanese copyright laws
are very different than American
copyright laws it's really hard to make
YouTube content about anime and not have
it copyright strike they get violated
just about that yeah so that's a big
limiting factor but hey there's American
animated stuff and there is a future in
which like we're gonna try to cover more
I mean we'll be covering Invincible
season two I know that's not actually
but it's uh animated style yeah I also
want to say on the subject of love the
new rockstars fandom may be the most
loving oh no
rockstars folks on the street it is a
very consistently very lovely
environment hey when you see me at
Disneyland shout me out you you already
do but I'll say hello I'll say hello
yeah every time we're at an event or a
con or something like that the nicest
people always say hello we appreciate
you so hey whoever you got somebody in
your life friend family member roommate
uh lover uh tell them Happy Valentine's
Day and Happy Valentine's Day to you you
know what even if you've got nobody else
uh celebrate yourself today give a
little self-love and I mean that in the
dirtiest possible way
flow thank you uh Corey for being on the
show today thank you to everybody for
watching we're taking tomorrow off
because we did that bonus Sunday episode
but we're coming back Thursday and
Friday Thursday we got that movie club
with Zombieland and we're gonna be
talking a lot of Ant-Man quantumania and
then Friday we're both talking more
quantumania and that's our big uh deep
dive launch pardon day subscribe to the
Deep dive check out the north VPN Link
in the description again norvpn Watch
Zombieland on Netflix Japan before it
gets irrelevant Because the Internet
moves very fast faster than the flash
also more movie trailers should do what
they did with the three minute Flash and
then 50 second because that was a really
inventive way to get us talking about it
twice and it didn't give too much away I
really liked like I would love to see
more companies do little like 30 40
second teasers throughout the year
instead of just the Super Bowl go online
and then have a big one yes and they get
that point too a lot more views on their
YouTube it was such a genius format I
was shocked at like how much that worked
and the Guardians trailer just broken
good job uh Eric's Guardians of the
Galaxy trailer breakdowns out on the
channel now check out his Flash trailer
breakdown uh lots of great content
coming this week for anybody on the
watch quantumania we'll have lots of
stuff on Thursday Friday Saturday so
much stuff check out the movie this
weekend if you have the time if you
don't whenever you check it out come
back to New rockstars check out all that
yeah maybe stay on YouTube for a couple
days if you are really hate spoilers and
are worried dude we are not gonna put
stuff in our thumbnails that will spoil
stuff other channels might and it's just
not worth it you know hey uh uh talk to
friends instead I don't know
um
uh regardless enjoy the rest of your day
whenever you're watching this we'll see
you next time
[Music]
thank you